Welcome back.
So where I left off, I was
hopefully trying to give you
an intuition of this inward
acceleration.
In this case, I have a rock
spinning around, and I'm
holding it on a string.
And I want to think about what
the inward acceleration is
dependent on.
And so we talked a little bit
about its velocity in these
multiple red arrows.
These are potential
velocity vectors.
So the point I was trying to
make is, if the velocity
vector is bigger, to change its
direction requires even
more acceleration.
Because the change in the x
direction is bigger, and then
the change in the y direction
is bigger.
Because for example, right here,
it's y-- I'll draw it in
a different color-- it's
y velocity vector.
And I'll do it for
the big velocity.
Its y velocity vector
was here.
And then now its y velocity
vector is almost essentially
the whole vector.
So when the velocity increases,
and let's say this
is the case of the big arrow.
If the velocity was less, like
the small arrow, its velocity
of vectors was here, and it
would have to go to here.
So I don't know if it's
completely obvious, but the
change in velocity, for example
in the y direction
over this course of time,
has to be more.
And likewise, the change in x
direction over this, and this
might be more obvious, because
here this is the x velocity
vector if the velocity
was less.
And this is the x velocity
vector if it was more.
And that's going to 0.
Between when the dot goes
from here to here.
Here it has no x component.
So clearly, I would have had
to decelerate in the x
direction more, if we have
a larger velocity vector.
I'm either giving you an
intuition, or I'm confusing
you, but I'll keep going.
So velocity clearly-- the
greater the velocity, the more
I'm going to have to pull
in on this one.
The more the inward acceleration
has to be to keep
this thing going
in the circle.
And not only does the
acceleration have to be bigger
just to get that velocity vector
down, but you've got to
realize when, between this
point and this point, the
faster I go, the less time it's
going to take me to get
from here to here.
So not only am I going to have
to change the velocity more, I
have to do that in less time.
So the velocity is affecting
this acceleration that I need
to pull in two ways.
So the higher the velocity, I
have to change more of the
velocity, and I have to
do it in less time.
And it actually turns out
that the acceleration is
proportional to the
velocity squared.
And then there's another
term, and I won't
prove it in this video.
I'm going to prove it
in another video.
And that might be out of your
scope just now, because it
requires some calculus.
But I want to give
you an intuition.
So we know that the acceleration
is dependent on
the velocity squared.
And I want to make that point of
why it's not just velocity,
because there's two ways that
the velocity is affecting how
much of an acceleration
I need.
One, is just the magnitude
of the velocity.
The more that is, the more I
have to accelerate to change
this direction.
And the second is, between this
point and this point, I
have less time to change
that velocity.
So the velocity affects
it in two ways.
And that's where you get an
intuition for the v squared.
The other thing that matters
is actually the radius.
So let's say this
is the radius.
And the acceleration
is inversely
proportional to the radius.
And why is that?
Well, it's kind of like the
second, I guess we can call
it, velocity argument I gave.
The bigger the radius.
So let's say that, let's look at
this rate and let's look at
another radius that is bigger.
Let's say that this
is another radius.
Let's say if the string
was longer and
this was another case.
Let's says this was the case.
But the velocity was the same.
So this is the case with a
larger-- so let's say it's the
same velocity vector.
So we have the same thing
at play, to go from
there to say, there.
We have to change the velocity
the same magnitude.
As we had to change the velocity
from here to here.
But one thing changes.
This distance is longer.
So if this velocity is the same
as this velocity, but
this distance is longer,
you have more time
to change the velocity.
So the larger the radius, the
more time you have to change
the velocity.
And so the less acceleration
you need.
Hopefully that makes sense.
Let me repeat it.
Because I think it's nice
to have the intuition.
Between this point and this
point, unless you have a
smaller radius, if I want to
change the acceleration vector
from that to that, I have
however long it takes to go
this distance.
I have that long to change
its velocity vector.
But if the radius was
a little longer.
And I had the same velocity, so
here the velocity is that.
And then here, the
velocity is that.
I have a little bit more time
to change its velocity.
And remember, acceleration is
just change in velocity over
change in time.
And so if I have the same change
in velocity, but I have
more time to do it with.
This is a bigger number.
The required acceleration
is less.
So maybe I've given
you an intuition.
And I will prove
this for sure.
Because this is kind of a very
touchy, very soft way, and not
very rigorous way of proving
that the required acceleration
to make something going in a
circle is v squared over r.
But accept that as a bit of
faith, and I'll prove it.
Especially once you learn your
calculus, and you can watch
that video.
And we could do a couple of
problems. And this is probably
what you care about anyway.
But I think it's nice to
have that intuition.
So once again, let's say
we're in deep space.
Let's do a little
orbit problem.
Let say that this is Earth.
I will do Earth in blue.
Let's say that is Earth.
And I have a satellite that
is going around Earth.
And I'm not going to calculate
its-- this is a satellite
that's going around Earth.
And I'm going to do a whole
other video on actually
figuring out the gravitational
force depending on how far
away you are from an object.
But let's just assume that its
gravitational force is similar
to what it is on the
surface of Earth.
And that is a big assumption,
or let's assume this is a
different planet and I'm going
to give you the gravitational
acceleration.
Let's say that the planet, and
maybe this isn't Earth, is
pulling inwards.
It always pulls towards
its center.
And I'll do that in
a different color.
That it's pulling inwards
at 30 feet per second.
My question is, what does the
velocity of the satellite have
to be for the object
to stay in orbit?
Well, we could just apply the
formula and then maybe we can
have a little intuition.
So acceleration is equal--
oh, I'm sorry.
Let's say that the object is
6,000 feet from the center.
And when we learn gravity, we'll
learn actually that it's
the distance from the radius
that you're going around is
actually relative
to the center.
Well, actually it's always
going to be,
because this is a circle.
So, the radius.
This is the center
of that circle.
You don't have to worry
about that.
It has nothing to
do with gravity.
OK, so the acceleration
is v squared over r.
Acceleration, we know is
30 feet per second.
We want to figure out the
velocity, and then the radius,
I said, is 6,000 feet.
So let's ignore the
units for now.
This could make things
complex.
Multiply both sides of this
equation times 6,000, so 3
times 6 is 18.
You'll have four 0's.
2, 3, 4.
So v squared is equal
to 18,000.
Everything's in feet
per second.
And so what's v?
So v is equal to the square
root of 180,000.
Let me get the calculator out,
because I haven't memorized my
perfect squares that high.
1, 2, 3.
Take the square root, so 424.
So the required velocity
is 424 feet per second.
So if the satellite is at that
velocity, it will go in
perfect orbit around
this planet.
Now what happens if
this object's
velocity is a little slower.
What happens-- let me do it in
a different color so you know
what I'm talking about.
What happens if its velocity
is a little
bit less than that?
Let's say its is 300
feet per second.
Well, then it's not going to be
able to travel far enough
tangent to the circle
to-- well, it'll
essentially just do this.
It'll always be getting
a little bit closer.
And it'll spiral in and
it'll hit the planet.
And another way to think about
what the required velocity is,
you have to go fast enough so
that you're always falling in.
But every time you fall in, you
want to go in this case,
the right enough so that you're
an equal distant--
you're still the same distance
away from the center.
So that your distance from the
center never changes if you're
going fast enough.
And then what happens if its
velocity is too fast?
What happens in the case
where its velocity is
600 feet per second?
Well, in that case, the object
will have enough velocity to
actually escape the orbit
of the planet.
But anyway, that's enough
about that.
I'm actually out of
time, so I'll see
you in the next video.